what's going on guys this is rob and
today on our beyond omega level series
we're going to discuss gladiator who is
one of the many iterations of marvel
superman uh and you guys will find out
exactly just how close this guy is to
superman arguably he's the closest thing
that marvel has maybe with the exception
of hyperion but gladiator whose real
name is khalak was created by chris
claremont and dave cockrum and first
appeared in x-men number 107 in 1977.
now for a bit of interesting background
here each of the members of the shiar
imperial guard were created as homages
to the legion of superheroes of dc
comics and gladiator is a homage to
superman or superboy depending on who
you're talking about but his name being
kallark is literally a mashup of the
names khalel and clark and the name
gladiator is a nod to the novel of the
same name that serves as an inspiration
for the creation of superman now kallark
belongs to a race of aliens called the
strontiums who fall under the control of
the shiar empire but the species
possesses great inherent strength and
were trained as cadets in service of the
empire now kalark stood out among all of
his peers and was among a group of 10
elite recruits that would have their
power levels greatly enhanced after
completing a series of trials and so the
final test presented to the cadets
before being elevated to the title of
gladiator was to go back to their home
planet of strontia and kill the
strontian council of elders now of the
10 people only kallark proved his
devotion by having the willingness to
obey this command as he carried out the
killing of the beings who were
responsible for raising him and his
loyalty was ultimately rewarded as he
was elevated to gladiator status and
named praetor of the shia imperial guard
basically its leader devoted to
protecting the leader of the shia empire
so like i said earlier once he was
promoted to gladiator kellogg's power
level increased drastically and since
we've established that gladiator was a
creation or created as a homage to
superman to superboy it comes as no
surprise that his power set is virtually
identical so that means of course that
he has super strength and i feel like
glidator is often overlooked in terms of
how strong he actually is and that's
probably because he's been written
pretty inconsistently over the years but
when we look at what he's done it
becomes clear this guy is definitely one
of the strongest characters in marvel
comics and it makes sense that he was
part of the annihilators so for instance
when he hits ben grimm ben states it was
the hardest hit he had ever endured and
this was after he had squared off with
the incredible hulk on more than one
occasion in a battle with invisible
woman who's bonded with the unipower
which is the power that gives
individuals the power of captain
universe gladiator not only held his own
but the two of them caused a tsunami
that threatened to destroy california on
another occasion gladiator was engaged
in a test of strength with hyperion and
both of them exerted enough force to
pulverize a planet but most notably
gladiator was able to punch a planet
apart with only a couple of hits also
although we don't see it happen on panel
the living tribunal states that
gladiator is capable of removing planets
from their orbits and collapse stars
with his bare hands furthermore
gladiator's son kid gladiator remarks
that his father can crack moons with his
punches and tear black holes apart and
gladiator himself says that he's flown
through stars and can move planets at
will so we're talking about an
absolutely insane level of strength when
it comes to this guy now in addition to
his strength gladiator also has
superhuman durability having survived an
explosion that would have annihilated
half of the solar system and was
completely unfazed by a blast from
vulcan who himself is basically omega
level furthermore gladiator laughed when
he was hit with the nova flame from the
human torch and red sun that was 100
million miles wide without suffering any
ill effects another often overlooked
aspect of gladiator's power set is his
super speed in terms of his reflexes
he's caught around from a sniper rifle
and when it comes to pure speed he's
been able to outrun photons which are
basically particles of light which means
he can travel faster than the speed of
light in fact reed richards actually
observed that he traveled at 100 times
the speed of light when he approached
the earth and also covered a distance of
multiple light years in a matter of
seconds on top of that gladiator
possesses microvision which allows him
to count 10 billion micro sentinels in
jean grey's bloodstream in an instant
but the similarities to superman don't
stop there
he also possesses a form of x-ray vision
and heat vision with his heat vision
being hotter than a star and powerful
enough to destroy asteroids turn air
into plasma and cause molecules to
vibrate so quickly that they burn
galactus also much like superman
gladiator possesses a form of frost
breath that was capable of snuffing out
the flame of the human torch who at his
absolute peak is as hot as the sun now
with all that in mind it's obvious that
gladiator is at least omega level i mean
we know he can destroy planets and it's
said that he's able to collapse black
holes so there really shouldn't be much
debate as to whether gladiator belongs
in the omega or even beyond omega level
tier unfortunately like i said earlier
he's been the victim of extremely
inconsistent writing throughout his
numerous appearances and i think the
result of this inconsistent writing is
that many readers vastly underestimate
his power level just to give an example
of what i'm talking about here on the
one hand we have all these feats that
should speak for themselves as to how
powerful this guy is but then we have
other instances where he's knocked down
by gambit
or has a hard time overpowering colossus
but this is a problem that has played
comic book characters for years and as
readers inconsistent writing is
something we are just gonna have to
accept that there are going to be
instances when the bad guy or antagonist
is going to be hurt by a character they
logically should be able to easily
destroy because that's what the story
calls for and when gladiator runs into
the x-men the x-men are ultimately going
to win because the book is called x-men
it's not called gladiator but at the end
of the day we have seen what gladiator
can do and we've seen him give the
phoenix 5 a run for their money in
avengers vs x-men the phoenix force even
when divided among 5 hosts is one of the
most powerful forces in marvel comics so
the fact that gladiator can even
challenge them is impressive so despite
all the inconsistencies in writing i'm
comfortable in saying that based on his
feats gladiator is easily omega level
and could potentially be classified as a
beyond omega level threat but let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section i'm really curious
because i'll be honest man people sleep
on gladiator this dude is just op but
we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace